(en ukrainien)
- Ce n'est que le début.
Mais déjà assez pour semer
la consternation chez
les consommateurs. Il n'y a
presque plus de sarrasin sur
les tablettes d'un des plus
grands supermarchés de Moscou.
Idem pour le riz, l'huile,
les pâtes et le sucre.
"Il n'y a plus de sucre
depuis trois jours", dit
cette employée d'Auchan
"J'ai voulu en réserver
deux sacs pour la maison,
mais tout est vendu", dit-elle.
Les gens achètent par panique,
alors que le rouble dégringole
et les prix augmentent.
Même que certains produits
sont déjà soumis aux ratios.
"Pas plus de cinq kilos par
personne", explique la pancarte.
Et ce n'est pas que pour
la nourriture : les serviettes
sanitaires font désormais partie
des produits essentiels qui
disparaissent à vue d'oeil
ces jours-ci.
"Les gens regardent trop
la télé, dit cette commis,
et se précipitent pour vider
les tablettes, c'est
de la folie".
Au centre commercial Atrium,
la nouvelle normalité commence
aussi à frapper les Moscovite.
Une boutique sur deux
n'est plus : Levi's, Mango,
Zara. Et chaque jour, une autre porte se ferme.
La chaîne Nespresso vient
d'annoncer qu'elle n'exporte
plus de capsules de café en Russie.
Ces gens font la file, résignés.
Et sur la célèbre place
Pouchkine, c'est McDonald's
qui tire officiellement
sa révérence aujourd'hui.
- Dmitry, 18 ans, n'était pas né
quand le McDonald's a ouvert
ses portes en 1990, mais il sera
un des derniers clients,
tout comme Katia et Paulina.
(en anglais)
Comme tant de jeunes
dans le monde, elles venaient
souvent manger après les cours
entre amies pour 150 roubles
ou même pas 3 $. Ce n'est pas
tant les burgers qui vont lui
manquer, mais ce que les arches
jaunes représentent.
- Ce sentiment, Andrei
se rappelle l'avoir vécu,
il y a 32 ans, quand il a fait
la file pour manger son tout
premier Big Mac.
"C'était un symbole
d'ouverture, de possibilités.
Mais ces occasions
disparaissent, la liberté
aussi."
En moins de trois semaines,
tout a changé. Le grand magasin
Adidas du centre-ville est
encore ouvert, mais seulement
pour quelques jours. Ces jeunes,
qui n'ont jamais connu la vie
sans les luxes importés
de la France ou de l'Amérique,
achètent tout ce qui reste.
Il a l'intention de tout
revendre sur le marché noir.
Il faudra s'y habituer.
- Forcé de constater que
son pays, la Russie, est devenu
l'un des plus sanctionnés
du monde. Plus de 500
entreprises ont plié bagages
Le gouvernement russe menace
désormais de saisir les biens
et de nationaliser celles
qui désertent le pays.
Svetlana dit qu'elle s'inquiète
pour les milliers de chômeurs,
mais elle est prête à tout
pour la gloire de son pays.
"Ce que je dis à ma fille,
surtout, c'est de ne pas avoir
honte d'être Russe, que notre
pays est un pays victorieux,
que la Russie a déjà vaincu
les nazis et qu'elle le fera
à nouveau."
Mais, comme tant d'autres,
elle est venue faire ses adieux
à McDonald's, elle aussi.
- Goodbye America